c'est une des conséquences de la fusion
des régions les services déconcentrés de
l'état se réorganise eux aussi selon
quels critères avec quelles conséquences
pour les usagers et pour les personnels
on en débat maintenant dans la voix est
libre une émission spéciale en direct de
la préfecture de dijon
bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 et nous
commençons cette nouvelle année
politique avec un rendez vous
exceptionnel à la préfecture de dijon
pour parler de la réforme des services
de l'état en bourgogne et en
franche-comté puisque la fusion de nos
deux régions entraîne de nombreux
changements avec la désignation de dijon
comme capitale et une répartition des
administrations sur les deux régions
dont jérémy bonjour lilian bonjour à
tous alors avec nous sur ce plateau cinq
invités d'abord éric delzant préfet de
bourgogne pour effet préfigurateur de
bourgogne franche comté vous avez à ce
titre réparti les directions des
différents services de l'état entre nos
deux régions face à vous une
représentante des fonctionnaires parce
qu'évidemment cette réforme préoccupe
les fonctionnaires dominique aubry
frelin vous êtes secrétaire régional de
la cfdt en franche comté en charge du
dossier aux réformes territoriales vous
êtes également secrétaire de la section
de votre syndicat au conseil régional de
franche comté
et puis il ya également sur ce plateau
trois invités qui représente trois
catégories d'usagers des services
publics
alors d'abord ludovic rochette vous êtes
président de l'association des maires de
côte-d'or et maire de brugnons membres
du parti et elle l'est républicain
jean-luc python vous représentez vous
les chefs d'entreprise vous êtes
président du medef de franche comté et
enfin christian magnin feysot président
de la rue qu'à franche comté une
association régionale des usagers des
services de soins bonjour à tous les 5
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bonjour jours et chez vous parce que
vous êtes tous concernés vous pouvez
bien sûr réagir sur nos deux sites
internet en bourgogne et en
franche-comté vos questions seront
posées à nos cinq invités dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission juste
après le flash de midi alors pour bien
comprendre de quoi nous allons parler je
vous propose de voir comment ont été
répartis les directions des différents
services de l'état entre les deux villes
préfectures aujourd'hui dijon est donc
besançon alors à dijon vient donc la
préfecture de région mais aussi l'
agence régionale de santé les direction
régionale des finances publiques la draf
l'alimentation l'agriculture la forêt la
jeunesse et sports cohésion sociale et
les affaires culturelles ainsi que la
cour régionale des comptes et le
rectorat
vous venez de voir à besançon un
rectorat de région les
direction régionale de l'environnement
l'aménagement et du logement ce qu'on
appelle la dréal mais aussi la direccte
tous qui gère l'économie
et puis enfin lille faisait une
présentation lilian qui a été présenté
comme équilibré
alors c'est la question qu'on doit bien
sûr posé à éric delzant vient de voir
deux plateaux de la balance
est ce que c'est une ventilation
équilibré et est ce que d'ailleurs
c'était l'objectif d'équilibré alors
d'abord sur quel principe cette réforme
est elle fondée trois principes
le premier c'est un principe d'
équilibre d'équilibré des territoires et
donc d' équilibre des capitales vous
venez de faire une présentation qui
n'est pas tout à fait exact parce que il
s'agit de la répartition des sièges
régionaux de ces grandes directions
régionales mais naturellement des
services de ces directions achats
resteront implanté dans chacune des
villes
je prends l'exemple de la direction
régionale de l'environnement
elle va être implanté avoir son siège à
besançon mais il y aura des services de
la dréal et donc des fonctionnaires de
la dréal qui continueront à être a dit
jean et qui continueront à travailler à
dijon donc
n'allons pas imaginer que en quelque
sorte au vide une des villes qui
seraient besançon par exemple au profit
de l'autre qui serait dit jean ou
réciproquement
le deuxième principe de cette réforme et
qui est très important aussi je crois il
faut que tous ceux qui nous écoutent le
comprenne bien c'est qu'elle est faite
pour plus d'efficience du fonctionnement
des services de l'état et plus
d'efficience du service public
je crois qu'on est à une époque où tous
les usagers du service public qui sont
d'ailleurs représentées ici on attendre
ce pseudo cette plus grande efficience
et plus grande efficacité cette réforme
est faite pour ça et puis elle est faite
aussi
troisième enjeu majeur parce que je
crois qu'il faut bien en avoir
conscience pour que on est encore une
fois un état qui soit modernisée dans
son mode de fonctionnement
ludovic rochette est ce que du côté des
politiques du côté des élus
côte-d'oriens que vous êtes il y avait
une inquiétude
un souhait une demande de
conserver des choses bien sûr nous ce
qui nous a heurtés au niveau national je
ne parle pas du niveau le calme c'est le
préfet au niveau national c'est cette
réforme qui était très brutale avec des
incertitudes qui ne sont pas forcément
totalement levé et bien sûr les élus que
ce soit 18 pour ino franc comtois et
après de la nouvelle région donc soit
extrêmement vigilants aux mouvements de
personnel qui pourrait se faire
et puis il ya ce qui va se passer aussi
au conseil régional
mais le préfet un raison ludovic
rochette vous attendiez vous en tant
qu'usagers que les services de l'état se
modernise soit plus efficient on ne
demande que ça on ne demande que que des
services de l'état et des services des
collectivités locales encore plus
efficient
on a des incertitudes après sur les
moyens financiers que ce soit dans le
cadre de la déconcentration de la
décentralisation jean louis vuitton la
même question finalement pour les chefs
d'entreprise c'est une réforme qui
allait vite un ace que de votre point de
vue il ya us qui a remonté du terrain
avec vos adhérents c'était la peur que
dans une région il ya des choses qui
soient plus là des interlocuteurs qui
disparaissent non les chefs
d'entreprises dont les milieux
économiques en général n'ont pas une
réaction de peur par rapport à cette
réforme
on a des interrogations nées des
attentes mais il n'y a pas de peur
l'horizon des entreprises c'est un
horizon international
le monde bouge et le monde bouge vite
donc il est évident que des réformes
sont nécessaires également en france ont
ceci dit la façon dont elle était
conduite nous interpelle un peu mais
c'est pas notre préoccupation en
première ligne
notre préoccupation c'est de savoir si
cette réforme conduire à des économies
ou pas et si elle générera une plus
value économique d'attractivité du
territoire qui on manque d'une façon
importante
et alors je vous renvoie la question
est-ce que selon vous cette réforme va
générer des économies vous et d'après ce
qu'on a compris il ya d'abord des
surcoûts un peut-être pas au niveau des
services de l'état mais au niveau en
tout cas des des conseils régionaux ça
paraît assez évident dans un premier
temps et les économies nous sont
présentés comme étant à terme et donc
peut-être un peu aléatoire en tout état
de cause mais
ça vous paraît plausible ou pas oui bien
sûr si enfin on voit d'ailleurs en ce
qui concerne la réorganisation de l'état
et on avait plus on n'avait pas des
excuses et moi on avait pas de doute par
rapport à salé l'êta en france et est
très fort très bien organisée et très
très compétent on sait qu'on a une des
meilleure organisation des pouvoirs
publics en france au monde met donc on
n'a pas d'inquiétude sur la possibilité
de mettre les choses en ordre et on voit
qu'elle se met effectivement en
bourgogne et franche comté en or d'une
façon assez précise et efficace et tous
les contacts que nous avons nous rassure
de ce côté là éric delzant au delà de
tout ça est ce qui a fallu aussi
équilibré négocier et faire en sorte que
tout le monde en sortent la tête haute
de sa en particulier les élus les maires
les présidents de collectivités
je crois qu'une bonne réforme c'est une
réforme qui ne fait pas se dresser les
uns contre les autres et en l'occurrence
qui ne fait pas se dresser les
territoires les uns contre les autres
il fallait pas que la réorganisation de
l'état en bourgogne franche comté soit
l'occasion d'un affrontement entre
précisément les deux capitales dijon et
besançon où entre les deux territoires
il fallait donc qu'elles soient
équilibrés et moi je considère que les
choix qui ont été faits par le
gouvernement que je mets en oeuvre sur
le terrain correspondent à cette
nécessité d'un équilibre
j'aurais rebondir sur ce que vous dites
sur la question des économies
oui cette réforme créera des économies
et comme toujours dans une réforme qui
se déroulent encore une fois sur le
moyen long terme ce n'est pas le 1er
janvier 2016 qu'on va constater les
économies bien entendu mais elle
générera des économies pourquoi parce
que le mode de fonctionnement de
l'administration sera plus efficace
parce que la modernisation des méthodes
de travail permettra de générer ces
économies je vous donne un exemple
aujourd'hui on fait se déplacer des
fonctionnaires des élus on leur fait
faire parfois deux ou trois heures de
route pour participer à des réunions
demain on va généraliser des méthodes de
travail qui permettront de faire ces
réunions en visioconférence avec des
systèmes de validation voir les
accusations
qui feront que les gens non plus
déplacés c'est quand même une économie
formidable de plus avoir à faire cinq
heures de route quand on vient nevers à
dijon pour participer une demi heure à
une réunion
pareil pour belfort et c'est donc voilà
le type d'économie qui vont être générée
alors évidemment elles vont se générer
dans la durée et l'organisation que je
mets en place est aussi une organisation
susceptible de générer des économies par
la mutualisation des services communs
par des méthodes de numérisation des
méthodes de recours aux techniques
modernes de communication qui feront
encore une fois que les fonctionnaires
travailleront de meilleures conditions
et donc générons des écoles alors on va
faire réagir dominique aubry frelin et
christian magnin feysot mais d'abord de
réaction à cette répartition des
directions d état-major des services de
l'état comment les élus locaux ont réagi
à vos annonces monsieur le préfet
c'était fin juillet je vous propose
d'écouter jean louis fousseret maire
socialiste de besançon et françois
sauvadet président du déni du conseil
départemental quotas moi ce que je
souhaitais dans un premier temps qu'elle
est bien conduit cette première étape
c'était qu'il n'y a pas de sentiment de
déclassement d'une ville par rapport à
l'autre on besançon aujourd'hui à des
services économiques emploi dijon
capitale administrative
voilà mon temps au travail je suis
satisfait ça pas été facile il a fallu
discuter beaucoup mais je dois dire que
la parole du premier ministre et du prix
de la république et demi la terreur a
été respectée voilà tout le monde est
content c'est les fans des femmes disent
et lilian pendant qu'on écoute et jean
louis fousseret et françois sauvadet est
ce que vous êtes contente et satisfaite
aussi dominique aubry frelin on va
attendre pour savoir si on est satisfait
que la réforme peut produire ses effets
maintenant c'est vrai que l'exigence de
la cfdt était sur l' équilibre des
territoires que le be site fonctionnel
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a expliqué
monsieur le préfet
une administration a son siège dans une
ville mais il y a un site secondaire
dans l'autre est partiellement
satisfaisante puisque nous ce que nous
avions revendiquer c'était qu'il y ait
enfin que les états-majors reste quand
même fait qu'il y ait une partie de
l'état-major dans chaque dans chaque
site
les personnels également craignent qu'en
le genre un directeur à dijon un
directeur attend à besançon c'est ça
éventuellement wii qui est vraiment une
précision c'est que l'objectif ça n'est
pas de dédoubler les administrations
régionales donc l'organisation elle va
être fonctionnel comme vous l'avez dit
c'est à dire que il y aura des services
qui seront dans une ville et d'autres
services dans une autre on va pas
évidemment maintenir les mêmes services
dans les deux villes sinon pour le coup
vous serez les économies en revanche et
ce qui est très important c'est qu'en
effet on va permettre aux agents ou
permettre aux fonctionnaires de limiter
les mobilités non choisie notamment et
on expérimentera en bourgogne franche
comté c'est la seule région de france on
va l'expérimenter ce qu'on appelle le
travail en sites distants qui va
permettre à des fonctionnaires tout en
étant dans un service qui serait par
exemple à dijon mais qui aurait été
auparavant affecté à besançon de
continuer à travailler a besoin sont de
manière distante
c'est ce que je vous disais éviter les
déplacements inutiles éviter tout ce qui
complique et qui renchérit surtout le
coût de fonctionnement des
administrations de dix ans je me permets
ce qu'on craint pas ce que craignent les
personnels c'est un écho vraiment du
terrain c'est que le bis sites
secondaires deviennent moins attractifs
alors excusez moi l'un des sites
secondaires oui c'est du charabia leleu
du travail qui ne sera pas chef lieu
comme des directions deviennent beaucoup
moins attractif et dépérissent
progressivement s'est juste fait un des
thèmes qu'on va aborder bien sûr dans la
deuxième partie cette émission ludovic
rochette vous vouliez réagir qu'avant
qu'on passe à monsieur martin saison oui
de deux pit idb une qui est essentiel
c'est que la fonction publique et la
fonction publique territoriale est
extrêmement dans une attitude
constructive aujourd'hui parce que la
situation des agents est compliquée que
ce soit dans les tables dans les
collectivités jouer vraiment saluer
cette attitude
deuxième point notre vigilance ça sera
aussi sur la présence de l'état
il ya la question des directions et puis
après il y aura là la présence
territoriale dont on sera extrêmement
vigilant à ce qu' il n'y ait pas une
autre vague ou des représentations
beaucoup plus local on a vu dans le cas
de la gendarmerie par exemple
dernièrement et biens ne soient pas
touchés alors un des points accueil dans
cette discussion on en a beaucoup parlé
certains disent même que c'est un
direction qui a fluctué au fil des
semaines jusqu'à la décision finale
c'est la rs l' agence de santé
christian magnin feysot vous êtes très
concerné par ce sujet et vous avez été
au coeur de sa ça s'est passé comment
est il vrai que la rsa fayette en
franche comté puis en bourgogne qui est
là qu'elle a vogué dit certains
observateurs jusqu'au 30 juillet c'est
exactement cela c'est à dire que
personne parmi nous n'y new york le 3
juillet le premier ministre s'est
déplacé avec huit ministres à besançon
et ce jour là le monsieur fousseret
maire de besançon par ailleurs président
du conseil de surveillance du chu de
besançon tonnelle après midi une réunion
de son conseil de surveillance de son
chru de besançon il éval il avait
l'assurance de monsieur le premier
ministre que l'arrêt serait en franche
comté
donc pendant tout le mois de juillet
l'espoir restait jusqu'à l' annonce du
31 juillet mais pas c'était cet espoir
déçu et ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure
par monsieur le préfet ce qui est très
très intéressant c'est que monsieur
lannelongue directeurs préfigurateurs de
l' ars de bourgogne franche comté et
monsieur tourancheau directeur général
par intérim de la rs de franche comté se
voit toutes les semaines depuis le 1er
janvier 2015 pour travailler sur
l'animation territoriale de santé pour
faire en sorte parce que ce sera notre
prochain rendez vous d'ici à peu près 18
mois 2 ans savoir comme le dit madame la
ministre de la santé
si on a réussi
développé à amplifier la proximité du
nivernais jusqu'aux vosges saônoises du
morvan jusqu'au jura et je pense qu'en
termes d'aménagement du territoire
la chose est totalement capitale il
faudra vraiment faire en sorte qu'on
fasse que le modèle franc comtois soient
répartis sur l'ensemble de la bourgogne
franche comté avec des conseils
territoriaux avec des animateurs de
santé polyvalents pour qu' on ne laisse
pas des gens au bord du chemin vis-à-vis
de la prévention du médico-social et des
soins un modèle franc comtois vous êtes
en train de dire cabba qui vous semble
qu'ils aient un modèle qui était
supérieur à l'autre
j'ai pas du tout dit ça mais je sais
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure monsieur le
préfet des landes le siège
c'est une chose l'animation territoriale
elle peut être largement partagé
c'est déjà en cours entre monsieur
lannelongue et monsieur tourancheau au
cso à un haut niveau des deux ars et
j'ai plutôt une grande confiance
vis-à-vis effectivement de cette
animation territoriale de santé mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce
va-et-vient vous l'avais dit au début
juillet le premier ministre en personne
s'engage auprès du maire de besançon le
siège de la rs sera à besançon et puis
finalement le 31 juillet ça a changé on
sait que la rsa a été le siège de la rs
à chaque fois on va préciser a été
donnée à des ville ex capitale régionale
dans plusieurs grandes régions entre
guillemets en compensation pourquoi
besançon n'a pas eu la rs selon vous
l'exemple que vous citez pour moi il ya
plein d'exemples c'est midi-pyrénées
languedoc-roussillon future région
grande région c'est effectivement la
capitale régionale de midi-pyrénées
languedoc-roussillon et toulouse et
effectivement la rs de cette grande
région est restée à montpellier nous
aurions pu caresser l'espoir que la
grèce reste en franche comté
mais maintenant passer ce cet espoir
déçu je pense qu'il faut travailler
ensemble v vis-à-vis d'une animation
territoriale de santé sur l'ensemble de
la bourgogne franche comté rit-elle sans
égard aux impatiences de vous répondre
je voudrais simplement dire que je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire monsieur finalement en
conclusion de ces propos ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est comment ça va
fonctionner demain au service de
l'ensemble des usagers et des patients
on sait très bien qu'une décision
connaît toujours avant qu'elle ne soit
prise et annoncée des tours et des
détours
vous avez des pressions notamment du
gouvernement c'est qu'il ya un ministre
qui est très attaché à la ville de dijon
par an je crois que le sujet vêtements
nettement le sujet il n'est plus là
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui est important dans des
négociations ce qu'est ce qui est
important demain c'est que
l'organisation de la rs qui sera
elle-même d'ailleurs sur les deux villes
en réalité puisque comme pour les
directions régionales dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure la rs sera organisé sur
les deux villes soit la plus efficace et
la plus performante pour conduire la
politique de santé dans la nouvelle
région
je voudrais d'ailleurs précisé que j'ai
proposé avec le directeur général
préfigurateur de la rs que le conseil de
surveillance de la rs qui est l'instance
nous sont représentés l'ensemble des
acteurs de la santé pour la rs soit se
réunissent et son siège se réunissent
systématiquement à besançon
c'est la preuve qu' il n'y aura pas
d'abandon encore une fois de ça je vais
revenir sur un autre sujet qui est très
important suit la proximité ça a été
évoqué un des fondamentaux de cette
réforme c'est le maintien de la
proximité pour les usagers il faut
savoir que la proximité c'est niveau
départemental beaucoup plus que le
niveau régional les directions
régionales reçoivent très peu de public
très peu de gens se rendent dans une
real dans une direct un peu plus à la
direction des affaires culturelles mais
c'est globalement des directions qui
reçoivent plus de public en revanche les
directions qui reçoivent beaucoup de
public c'est les directions
départementales et la réforme va
conforter l'échelon départemental elle
va même le renforcer puisqu'on va avoir
des services qui verront à la fois plus
de moyens et plus de compétences
est ce cette proximité assuré par le
niveau départemental ça fait partie des
fondamentaux de cette réforme
dominique aubry vous dirigez les gens
les pitots sur cette proximité de
proximité je crois que tout le monde
s'entend pour revendiquer la proximité
mais on n'est pas forcément nés
les mêmes mots sous 16 enfin les mêmes
réalités sous ce mot et vous avez parlé
beaucoup monsieur le préfet dé delà de
l'administration 3.022 l'évolution vers
le télétravail vers la visioconférence
une somme qu'il est un petit peu dommage
que il ya peut-être une opportunité qui
a été un peu raté que cette réforme soit
l'occasion non pas seulement de de
rénover les services des administrations
de l'état
mais la manière de travailler sur le
territoire en associant l'ensemble des
l'ensemble des partenaires que ce soit
des services de l'état les collectivités
les entreprises les partenaires sociaux
le dialogue social territorial il l'est
encore vraiment très très balbutiant et
je ne suis pas sûr que la seule réponse
or on conforte les directions
départementales soit une réponse de
proximité enfin une réponse complète en
termes de proximité et en plus on
déshabille et un peu les dr pour les
directions régionales pour habiller les
directions départementales alors que le
gouvernement précédent avait fait
l'inversé
c'est vrai que c'est un peu difficile à
suivre pour nous jean-luc python oui il
y à agir vous le franc comtois je
précise tout à fait alors de deux
remarques d'une part lorsque vous
essayez de mettre en évidence
dijon et besançon et l' équilibre entre
ces deux grandes villes
il ne faut pas oublier que niveau de la
bourgogne franche comté
nous avons également d'autres parties du
territoire et notamment le nord franche
comté
il a quand même le troisième site
industriel de france qui qui est à
sochaux le 31e qui est à vesoul
les sites les sites bourguignons sont un
peu je pressés derrière mais pour les
bourguignons notamment qui ne saurait
pas donc ses deux usines psa
effectivement à sochaux et à vesoul
voilà qu on oublie souvent vesoul mais
effectivement c'est une très grosse
usine
sachant qu'on saône et loire il ya
également deux des sites industriels
très important est que le patient si
vous permettait de compléter le bassin
industriel de ce qu'on appelle les rues
urbaine belfort montbéliard héricourt
est un des principaux de france tout à
fait donc il ne faut pas où
lle que effectivement le schéma ne se
réduit pas à la position réciproque et
équilibrée de entre entre dijon et
besançon
la deuxième chose c'est au niveau de la
répartition départementale
il ya quand même une certaine surprise
du monde économique de voir que à la
fois les mouvements d'organisation de
l'état ont privilégié les préfectures de
département pendant pendant plusieurs
années pour des raisons également de
bonne gestion des deniers publics et
d'économie et d'organisation mais avec
le sentiment qu'un certain nombre de
territoires se sentent un peu isolé
l'ain on pense par exemple dans le
domaine de santé aux services d'urgence
et quand même un souci majeur est que
d'un autre côté l'état ne va pas
peut-être jusqu'au bout de la logique
qui aurait peut-être était de supprimer
les sous préfectures
on maintient des sous-préfectures donc
des coûts alors que le service est de
moins en moins apporté par lesdites
préfecture ou au niveau local
et puis l'autre point également c'est
que le parlement en adoptant la loi
notre il y avait une ambition qui était
de réduire et voire peut-être même de
supprimer les départements et à la
sortie on se retrouve avec un empilement
des compétences qui forcément au niveau
des collectivités locales va générer des
coûts les choses ne sont jamais si
simple vous savez hier je rencontrais
les grands responsables de la
viticulture à beaune
je leur ai dit qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la réforme territoriale ils m'ont dit
la première chose qu'on vous demande de
ce préfet s'est pas supprimer la
sous-préfecture de bonnes parce que pour
nous et pour le monde de la viticulture
c'est essentiel d'avoir sur place un
sous-préfet en l'occurrence une sous
préfète aujourd'hui éric delzant quand
on habite à beaune dijon c'est trop loin
écoutez il faut poser la question aux
usagers ce n'est pas une question de
distance
c'est une question d'implication du
représentant de l'état dans
l'arrondissement avec le monde
économique par exemple alors cela étant
dit notre pays bouge et les besoins
évoluent aussi
c'est très bien que les temps dit pour
être caricatural éric delzant est ce que
ça changerait quelque chose à la vie
quotidienne des français que je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable qu'on ferme
la moitié des sous-préfectures qu'on
ferme des directions régionales signer
dié d'une administration est ce qu'en
réalité dans la vie quotidienne des
français ça changerait quelque chose est
ce qu'on n'est pas en train de parler de
quelque chose qui concerne pas vraiment
les français alors la vie quotidienne ça
dépend de quoi on parle par exemple tout
ce qui est une façon de la discussion
sur les conséquences de cette réforme ce
qui est délivrance des titres par
exemple on sait très bien que à terme
cette délivrance sera soit totalement
dématérialisé soit effectivement assurée
par d'autres sans doute organisation que
celle des sous préfectures qui
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup d'entre elles
ne délivre plus de titre aujourd'hui
par contre vous avez une fonction tout à
fait essentiel du sous-préfet qu'est
justement le dialogue territorial
monsieur le président des maires de la
côte d'or le sait bien les maires ils
veulent pouvoir parler avec leurs sous
préfet quand il prépare la révision de
la carte intercommunale
si avec le sous préfet qu'ils le font
donc le sous préfet un rôle majeur à cet
égard vis-à-vis de ces de ses usagers
vous évoquez ça tout à l'heure que sont
les maires les usagers de l'état 1 et
donc je crois qu'il ya une fonction
essentielle du sous préfet mais c'est
vrai que la carte des sous-préfectures
doit évoluer le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a dit il ya des territoires où il y
aura peut-être besoin d'ailleurs d'avoir
une nouvelle sous préfecture puis des
territoires auront peut-être on va
réviser la carte des sous-préfectures
axa fait partie de votre réflexion
justice elle pas celle de la réforme de
l'état territorial qui rentrera en
vigueur le 1er janvier 2016 c'est pour
le coup d'après mais on a déjà
évidemment ça en tête vous réfléchissez
déjà au coup d'après forcément
concrètement puisqu'on a expliqué selon
quels critères vous aviez choisi ça
s'était mis en place concrètement
maintenant la mise en place est ce que
ça signifie si on choisit des régions
pour y placer des directions régionales
qu'on ferme des sites et que des
personnels de l'administration s'en va
bouge dominique aubry de votre point de
vue c'est ce qu'on vous a dit vous avez
obtenu des garanties comment ça va se
passer pour les fonctionnaires
je crois qu'il la prend fin la peur
immédiate du fonctionnaire c'est la
mobilité géographique
mais là la mobilité géographique ne sera
certainement pas ce qu'il est ce qu'ils
les impactera le plus en fait
on estime que vous me contredirez
monsieur le préfet si je me trompe 1000
déplacement dans les personnels de
l'état pour 30000 qui ne bouge pas mais
un moment donné si vous avez le choix
entre changer de ville et changer de
métier c'est des fois plus compliqué de
changer de métier et de ce point de vue
là c'est vrai que la cfdt demande une
vraiment une négociation nationale sur
l'accompagnement en termes de formation
parce que ça c'est vraiment l'adaptation
passe par la formation je pense que
personne ne me contredira
sur ce point éric delzant justement les
chiffres en bourgogne franche comté les
mobilités vont concerner que combien de
fonctionnaires alors d'abord il faut
bien avoir en tête de qui on parle
1 si on parle de l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires de l'état qui travaillent
dans l'ensemble des services régionaux y
compris le périmètre rectorat ars etc on
est à peu près à 3000 pour bourgogne et
franche-comté tout compris donc c'est un
périmètre quand même important
là-dessus combien il va y en avoir qui
vont faire mobilité c'est encore trop
tôt pour le dire précisément parce que
je rappelle que les organisations
nouvelles ne sont pas encore
définitivement arrêté je prendrai les
dispositions qui vont bien après que la
phase du dialogue social aura eu lieu
que les comités techniques se seront
réunies donc tout ça et pour le mois de
décembre
ce qui est clair c'est que on sera sur
des effectifs effectivement de quelques
centaines de fonctionnaires qui sont
impactés nécessairement par une mobilité
qu'elle se lors de votre présentation
parce que vous n'allez pas le dire mais
lors de votre présentation fin juillet
vous avez dit à la presse entre 100 et
400 fonctionnaires est ce qu on est
toujours sur celui on est comme chez moi
je viens dire quelques centaines dont
vous voyez qu'on n'est pas loin de votre
fourchette
la question c'est pourquoi des mobilités
et pourquoi éventuellement ou comment
éventuellement éviter des mobilités
inapproprié on a clairement des
fonctionnaires de catégorie c des
fonctionnaires d'exécution qui ont des
revenus quand même pas très importants
pour qu'ils vont bouger et devient un
véritable problème familial le conjoint
un autre emploi on va pas obliger ces
gens à déménager même si c'est
simplement à 150 km je crois qu'il ya un
vrai problème là humain deuxièmement
vous avez un sujet d'organisation vous
avez des
jean y compris deux niveaux catégorie à
qui en ce qu'on appelle des compétences
rares ses compétences rares elles sont
utiles et parfois la mobilité va
perturber les l'exercice de ses
compétences sera donc on va essayer de
mettre en place des dispositifs c'est ce
que j'évoquais avec le travail en sites
distants pour justement permettre aux
gens de continuer à travailler sur place
tout en étant affectés ailleurs et là
aujourd'hui on a clairement si vous
voulez laisser un peu aussi la question
du du travail
comment dire
des modes de travail distancié on a eu
notre manière de travailler je crois que
les entreprises le pratiquent
aujourd'hui je parlais avec la
directrice de la banque de france la
banque de france nous a expliqué
aujourd'hui que 10% de ses cadres font
du travail à domicile avec des modes
sécurisé je crois que le travail demain
va être différent du travail
d'aujourd'hui dans le tertiaire
évidemment et que la réforme de l'état
elle est une occasion de changer
complètement les modes de travail
tellement je vous coupe mais vous parlez
de travailler à distance mais des
visioconférences des audioconférences
c'est des choses qui existent depuis 15
ans et est ce que c'est parce que
l'administration est très en retard ou
et c'est parce que la spécificité de
votre travail implique d'énormes de la
sécurité des choses comme ça qui font
que c'est plus compliqué que pour
d'autres parce que j'en ai dit on lui
demandera m'enfin le monde de
l'entreprise ce genre de chose le fait
depuis juin très long sur la leyre
devrait faire sourire sourire un p'tit
peu que la raison sourire de ce piton
parce que nous sommes terriblement en
retard nous sommes terriblement en
retard à cet égard nous avons beaucoup
de retard par rapport au monde de
l'entreprise bien entendu parce que
parce qu'en fait on n'a pas voulu se
donner à un moment donné la peine de
d'utiliser ces techniques modernes
alors après on a des vrais sujets de
sécurité effectivement on peut pas tout
à fait en effet organiser des
visioconférences sans avoir dé mode
sécurisé mais je crois surtout qu'il
faut aujourd'hui rattrapé ce retard il
faut être volontariste dans cette
nouvelle organisation du travail et
volontarisme ces nouveaux modes de
communication
c'est l'occasion de l'être et je peux
vous assurer que ce sera le cas ici en
bourgogne franche comté alors éric
delzant on va fusionner des directions
régionales ça veut dire qu'on va aussi
en plus des mobilités supprimer des
postes
combien de postes de fonctionnaires
seront supprimés notamment dans les
états majors une fois que la réforme
sera mise en place par exemple il y
avait il ya aujourd'hui deux préfet de
région demain il y en aura plus qu'un
seul ça c'est la suppression symbolique
ça va concerner combien
il y aura toujours excuser ou non mais
le préfet ce qu'aujourd'hui le boîtier
de franchement il y aura c'est le préfet
du doubs qui aura toujours un préfet du
doubs mais il y aura plus qu'un seul
préfet de région
il y aura plus qu'un seul directeur
régional pour toutes les directions
régionales
au delà de ce symbole je crois que notre
pays est engagé sur une trajectoire de
réduction de ses déficits publics
50 milliards d'euros d'économies dansez
dansez impératifs de la réduction des
déficits publics
il ya évidemment la réduction d'un
certain nombre de moyens de
fonctionnement des administrations
publiques de l'état et notamment de
l'emploi donc c'est le parlement qui le
sera puisque c'est dans la loi de
finances donc je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui quel sera le triennal 2016
sissach exemple que la baisse des
effectifs naturel la baisse naturelle
des effectifs dans les 5 grandes
directions régionales en bourgogne
franche comté c'est moins 20% d'ici 2020
oui absolument c'est à dire ils seront
remplacés ces fonctionnaires qui partent
on va rester sur cette trajectoire lors
vous avez bien compris qu'on ne
reviendra pas sur cette trajectoire
domicours et voulez oui en fait je
voulais donner les chiffres et que vous
venez poneys et qui nous inquiète
effectivement en termes d'effectifs boss
ils sortent des des documents de la
préfecture ils sont ils sont pas secret
pour personne donc moins - 12 % d'ici
trois ans et -1 21 % d'ici 2020
effectivement si tout aussi rien n'a
rien et remplacé de ces départs en
retraite ça va très très mal
mais sans vouloir présenter cette
répartition des directions comme une
répartition gagnant gagnant entre dijon
et besançon
mais en fait les deux villes vont perdre
des fonctionnaires silence de cathédrale
christian manière moi ce qui me paraît
intéressant ce qui concerne la
répartition des effectifs des
fonctionnaires
en ce qui concerne l' agence régionale
de santé bourgogne franche comté
je pense que la répartition 38 % en
bourgogne 32 % en franche-comté me
paraît équilibré me semble-t-il par
rapport aux besoins affichés par la
franche-comté la bourgogne
je ne peux parler que de ce domaine là
le reste effectivement je le laisse à la
vigilance de madame aubry frelin et du
préfet des landes et et ludovic rochette
vous qui êtes élu
et lui des républicains et conseiller
départemental par ailleurs est ce que
vous regardez la bouteille dans sa
moitié économie publique où vous la
regardez en tant que maire dans sa
moitié
on a besoin des fonctionnaires de l'état
quand on est maire quand on est usagé
qu'est-ce que vous prenez la branche
je pense aux contribuables parce que ça
pourrait être la double peine
un état qui réduit ses dépenses qu'on en
a besoin
les collectivités qui doivent réduire
leurs dépenses et en ce moment on est
quand même très vise à mal avec la
baisse des dotations et on à la mise en
question vraiment dès l'année prochaine
de la qualité de nos services auprès de
la population
donc l'enjeu fondamental c'est de savoir
comment ce qu'on peut répondre à ce
double contexte et les élus et les
associations représentantes sont là
justement pour avoir un niveau d alerte
mais on aura les honneurs la
démonstration prochaine est ce que pour
vous moins de fonctionnaires notamment
de fonctionnaires d'état ça veut dire
moins de services publics moins de
services au public
c'est surtout la question d'un
territoire et la territorialisation de
la présence de l'état
ce que joue actuellement c'est con on a
des grands des grandes questions sur les
sous préfectures
on a des questions sur la gendarmerie
sur la trésorerie
notre but à tous c'est d'arriver à avoir
des services efficaces pour un coût qui
soit supportable jeu il ne faudrait pas
oublier la présence territoriale parce
que comme vous l'avez dit tout n'est pas
qu'à dijon tout n'est pas qu'à besançon
on a des territoires qui ne doivent être
absolument pas oublié est-ce que cette
territorialité et les dans cette grande
parce qu'on parle de région en fête et
on parle pas on a peu parlé de ce niveau
territorial est-ce que vous dans votre
réflexion de préfet préfigurateurs il ya
aussi le niveau départemental voir plus
bas bien sûr cette question de la
présence des services publics est
essentiel de réponses qui sont apportées
aujourd'hui et qui sont développés les
maisons de l'état là où il ya un nombre
de sous préfecture notamment les plus
rurales regroupés dans ses sous
préfecture un certain nombre de services
de l'état qui sinon on risquerait de
partir par exemple ceux de la direction
départementale des territoires parfois
même ceux de
l'inspection d'académie pour avoir un
pôle de service public
implantée là et finalement on
rationalise on mutualisent on rend les
choses plus efficace les maisons de
services au public qu'est ce que c'est
on va en créer cinq nouvelles en côte
d'or l'année prochaine avec la poste
ce sont dans les locaux de la poste un
certain nombre de services services au
public parce qu'ils sont pas forcément
des administrations publiques par
exemple assurance maladie allocations
familiales mais aussi la sncf ou erdf et
et gaz de france vont faire des prêts à
man ans ou plus exactement des agents de
la poste représenteront ses services il
y aura une information du public
donc on va être plus présents sur le
territoire on tient compte de la
nécessité qu'ont toutes les
organisations aujourd'hui public de
effectivement reconsidérer leur mode de
fonctionnement pour faire des économies
mais faire des économies ne veut pas
dire qu on déserte le territoire et je
crois que l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
celui là
faire des économies en même temps
assurer la présence nécessaire que tous
les citoyens et que tous les usagers
demandent mais encore une fois il faut
être conscient que notre pays doit faire
des économies doit réduire ses déficits
et ça ça oblige qu'on peut pas rester
immobile jean-luc python votre
entreprise est située à quelques
kilomètres d'une sous-préfecture où les
gens se sont mobilisés parce qu'ils
perdaient des services publics ce que je
veux parler de lure en haute-saône où
les gens sont arrivés après avoir perdu
leur tribunal une partie des services
hospitaliers
le commissariat de police voilà il ya eu
plusieurs départs comme ça ils sont en
arriver et ça a surpris beaucoup de
personnes notamment en bourgogne à
manifester pour garder une prison est ce
que quand vous entendez ce que propose
éric delzant c'est à dire des maisons
service public une nouvelle
réorganisation territoriale est ce que
vous dites c'est ce qui pourrait
effectivement convenir à nos territoires
oui bien sûr il est indispensable que
l'état se réformant soit à la fois
présent efficaces et coûtent moins au
contribuable et que on évite qu'il y ait
des augmentations fiscales et de
fiscalité également par ailleurs et si
vous parlez de lure est un enjeu
important aussi allure aujourd'hui c'est
l'arrêt du train intercités qui mène à
paris
de la ligne 4 qui accepta rival l'ex-
paris-bâle devenu paru mulhouse et
maintenant paris belfort
concrètement juste alors c'est un petit
peu terre à terre et ce qui aura aussi
des opérations immobilières éric delzant
est-ce qu'en fermant des directions
régionales l'état veut gagner de
l'argent en cédant des sièges des
directions régionales ou des choses
comme ça parce que c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser aussi alors à court
terme non puisque comme je voulais dit
on maintient les services dans les
villes mais par exemple il ya un projet
aujourd'hui à besançon le projet
besançon viotte on va voir qui
regroupera un symptôme de service qui
permettra de faire des économies
importantes de de replantation
immobilière de besançon et je crois
besançon viotte c'est le bon exemple de
ce que nous allons faire
je suis moi même en train de réfléchir
de voir comment à moyen terme on
pourrait avoir un projet de même nature
à dijon à dijon elle en fait poursuit
c'est quoi ces regroupés les
administrations proche des gars et ça
oui l'idée c'est d'avoir une amie un
fonctionnement de l'administration de
garaga de manière à ce que si les
fonctionnaires doivent circuler il
moines trajet à faire et puis en même
temps on peut rationaliser parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des implantations
avec des loyers qui sont souvent trop
élevé
donc on peut regrouper mutualiser des
fonctions
voilà je crois que c'est ça l'avenir
alors ça se fait pas je le dis tout de
suite ce sera vous ne le verrez pas le
1er janvier 2016 parce que biot d'abord
c'est 2018 ce sera fini en 2018 tant
mieux ré 6 pour viol
en fait c'est un projet donc à côté de
la gare viotte a besoin sont en centre
ville qui va permettre de regrouper à
peu près 800 vols finnair qui sont
aujourd'hui répartis sur une dizaine de
saintes et à terme notamment sur
l'immobilier l'état économiserait 400000
euros par an voilà c'est un modèle
j'imagine ah bah écoutez en tout cas
c'est le plus important projet de cette
nature en france aujourd'hui
ça rentre dans la mission qu'on vous a
confié puisqu'on l'a dit mais par
incidents depuis le début de cette
émission le préfet préfigurateurs que
vous êtes aspect si façon spécifique
on lui a demandé de travailler sur
justement les nouvelles techniques
comment bien sûr on va moderniser tout
ça ça ça rentre dedans bien sûr
évidemment on peut pas imaginer encore
une fois ce qu'on m'a demandé c'est pas
juste d'écrire des organigrammes ce
qu'on m'a demandé c'est comment l'état
territorial fonctionnera mieux
et pour rendre mieux le service public à
partir de 2016
c'est ça l'enjeu survireuse vous aurez
un point à régler qui est la desserte
entre la gare tgv et la gare de biot
avec des horaires adaptés ou alors il ya
des navettes aujourd'hui dizaines par
jour je crois mais oui effectivement
certaines navette il ya moins de
navettes que deux tgv qui s'arrête
dominique aubry
monsieur le préfet disais tout parlé
tout à l'heure de 10 on a pris du retard
dans notre façon de travailler dans le
l'administration est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous partagez et est
ce que ces nouveautés de cité
administrative de gare à gare est ce que
ça vous semble des points positifs pour
les personnels pour les personnels il
est clair que le retard est très
difficile enfin bon je crois que vous ne
vous étonnerez pas en vous disant que le
dialogue social traîne un peu les pieds
et qu' il est urgent de discuter avec
les personnels parce que si
l'organisation de internationale du
travail cit trois phases dans le
dialogue social informations
concertation négociations on en est tout
au plus à la phase 1 un an qu'il
faudrait il faudra un moment que puis
c'est vrai que la fonction publique
n'est pas le lieu idéal du dialogue
social un ça se saurait mais comment
vous prenez les critiques qui sont assez
générales et récurrente en france ait eu
encore un rapport de la cour des comptes
cette semaine qui a pointé du doigt le
coût de la fonction publique en france
monsieur le préfet dit on va être plus
efficace ça veut dire quand même que
aujourd'hui l'administration ne l'est
pas tout à fait quand on est
fonctionnaire comment on réagit gaza ont
écouté quand on est fonctionnaire des
gens on a l'habitude d'être critiqué par
la population mais qui en même temps
demande quand même plus d'enseignants
plus d'infirmières plus de policiers
enfin plus de fonctionner en clair
aucune qu'une administration cherche à
être efficace ça ne vous choque pas a
priori
maintenant il ya un moment où on va
arriver sur l'os quoi quand même
ja on n'en est pas à la première réforme
de l'état donc faire mieux faire mieux
avec moi oui si on démontre comment on
peut y arriver oui
éric delzant oui d'abord moi je voudrais
rendre hommage au travail de tous les
fonctionnaires de l'état mais des
collectivités aussi qui travaillent en
bourgogne franche comté parce que je
crois que globalement la qualité du
service public est rendu est très bonne
et d'ailleurs finalement il ya ce
paradoxe que vous avez relevé madame
c'est à la fois il ya une espèce de
critiques générales de l'état et de ses
fonctionnaires et puis finalement c'est
un message d'amour qu'on leur adresse
dans bien des circonstances ne serait ce
que parce que quand on annonce qu'on va
fermer une administration et supprimer
des emplois les gens protestent mais je
crois qu'ici vous avez raison cette
réforme ne sera pas sans un dialogue
social approfondi
l'urgence dans laquelle nous avons été
par rapport aux décisions politiques qui
ont été prises n'a sans doute pas permis
de le développer autant qu'il aurait
fallu je suis certain je vous le dis
clairement ce matin il n'est que temps
de l'approfondir d'ici à ce que tout
soit mis en place
tout ça nous amène sur les conséquences
à plus long terme de cette réforme
on vient d'essayer de se poser des
questions sur la mise en place mais est
ce qu'à plus long terme
tout cela va changer le positionnement
des villes est ce que ça peut être de
nature je pose la question aux
côte-d'oriens que vous êtes ludovic
rochette a changé à créer des appels
d'air est ce que vous pensez par exemple
et monsieur python nous dira aussi son
son idée là dessus que une ville qui a
plus de siège de direction régionale
plus de choses ça va faire un appel
d'air pour des entreprises pour pour de
l'activité est-ce que c'est vu comme ça
par les élus les entreprises ont bien
besoin en ce moment
mais la question c'est de savoir si on
est dans une phase pérenne une phase
transitoire pour la fusion parce que
notre notre discussion aujourd'hui on
pourrait se retrouver dans quelques mois
avec le même sujet sur le conseil
régional
ça sera réussi s'il ya une bonne bonne
adéquation entre ce que fait l'état
entre ce que vont faire les
collectivités locales et dans la loi
notre et bien on peut avoir quelques
inquiétudes et des choses comme la
suppression de la clause de compétence
générale qui éclaircit les choses on
explique pour les gens qui nous
regardent la clause de compétence
générale ça permettait aux collectivités
de faire ce qu'elle voulait surtout les
usa là pour faire très très chère très
ça voilà donc maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui est éclairci par contre dans
l'application de des compétences par
exemple on parlera très prochainement de
la question du transport scolaire dans
le cadre de la fusion
là on est on est vraiment encore dans
des discussions obscures je répète ça ne
sera réussie que si on arrive à rebondir
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
l'échelon de trop on est dans une phase
peut-être on regrette le conseiller
territorial qui était une réforme que tu
es enfin de la majorité précédent
week-end à une réforme qui était assez
intelligente on vous n'êtes pas
complètement répondu à mes questions sur
l'appel d'air jean-luc python est ce que
quand on est représentant patronal on se
dit est ce que ne pas avoir certaines
directions ça peut inciter par exemple
des entreprises ou où je t'ai pas
d'autre des projets culturels à ne pas
se faire à un endroit ou pas oui bien
évidemment
la suppression d'un certain de service
public dans certaines villes où le
diminution du nombre d'agents c'est
valable à luxeuil pour la b à 116 ont
parlé de la prison de lure la base
aérienne le le le risque était majeur
effectivement pour besançon de perdre
plusieurs milliers de d'emploi de
salariés la fonction publique qui est
résident est bon ce risque est évacué
aujourd'hui mais pour le pour les
commerçants c'est un enjeu majeur
il ya des villes qui effectivement
perdre de la vitalité qui meurent
progressivement par le départ d'un
certain nombre de d'organisation qui
faisait vivre ces villes mais on est
d'accord quand même temps des
déplacements de directions régionales
auront pas forcément
réel impact dans le cas dans le cas
présent ce qui était ce qui est mise en
oeuvre d'une façon préfiguration
d'ailleurs parce que c'est une petite
ambiguïté puisqu'on parle de chefs lieux
provisoire on parle de préfet
préfigurateurs et de deux directeurs
d'hôtels chat vidéo provisoire lé préfet
préfigurateurs sont là pour durer au
moins peu pour devenir des chefs lieux
dès que les prévenus il faudrait sortir
de l'ambiguïté quand même assez
rapidement mais on n'a pas d'inquiétude
derrière on sortira l'ambiguïté tels que
tel que s'est dessiné jeu je le pense
enfin je pense pas qu'il y ait
d'inquiétude interne à la fonction
publique sur le fait que tel chef de
service qui est nommé chef de service
préfigurateurs a vocation à devenir le
réel chef de service derrière
si vous permettez de rebondir c'est
exactement ce que disaient aussi jean
louis fousseret le maire de besançon à
l'issue des discussions et quand éric
delzant a rendu ses conclusions
il nous a dit à nous la presse on s'est
beaucoup battu pour finalement quelques
dizaines quelques centaines de
fonctionnaires mais c'est surtout de
l'ordre du symbolique et le symbolique
c'est aussi ce l'appel d'air dont par
les lignes on peut le voir par exemple
sur une structure publique ou
parapublique comme edf gdf des on va
voir les images les des salariés de
besançon ont démonté il ya quelques
semaines la plaque de leur direction
régionale pour la remplacer par une
plaque provisoire antenne de dijon donc
il ya en tout cas une peur une crainte
de beaucoup d'agents bisontin finalement
que des transferts en masse de besançon
vers vers dijon
dominique aubry frelin donc vous le
sentez aussi vu ça ça remonte au niveau
syndical ce genre de craintes on voit
les images
oui c'est effectivement une crainte qui
remonte sur la pérennité finalement dû
de l'equilibre quoi il ya un relatif
équilibre qui est trouvée aujourd'hui et
mais pour combien de temps ça c'est
clair que c'est des inquiétudes mais
mais tout tout changement provoque des
inquiétudes mais dans le sens inverse
aux siens quand il ya une direction
régionale qui et comment dont le siège
est à besançon dijon ce enfin ce divin
finalement pour certes pour faire qu une
carrière de fonctionnaire il va falloir
aller à besançon c'est c'est dans les
deux sens sauf qu'il y en a plus à dijon
monsieur manifesto le maillage de santé
quand on parlait d'appels vers il est
primordial pour les villes aussi je
pense que en ce qui concerne le domaine
de la santé et de la rs bourgogne
franche comté on est plutôt protégé
vis-à-vis de ce système parce que sans
connaître dans le détail
l'animation territoriale de santé de
bourgogne et franche comté
les effectifs dont j'ai parlé en
pourcentage 38% pour la bourgogne est
32% pour la franche comté nous
paraissent à un gage de pérennité
vis-à-vis des emplois sur cette
thématique
alors il ya ce plan et il ya un mot que
vous avez prononcé ces pérennité est-ce
que
il peut y avoir un plan suivant parce
que bon on est à peu près sûr 30% on va
dire le répéter la norme nationale à peu
près 30% des directions donner à
d'autres villes est ce que le prochain
plan d'économies de l'état pourrait pas
logiquement dire dans trois ans dans
quatre ans imaginons scénario d'un
changement de majorité nationale dira
mais il faut faire des économies on
rapatrie tout le monde dans la capitale
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui peut se
passer
éric delzant je peux évidemment pas dire
ce qui se passera dans 4 ou 5 ans doute
gens que j'ai peut être nous s'il ya des
garde-fous et de sécurité pour les
personnels ce que je peux dire c'est que
les décisions qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement cet été
elles ont vocation à être pérenne autant
que on a voilà une visibilité est
évidemment politique et je crois que
c'est important cette stabilité
je pense que à la fois les élus
l'ensemble des usagers du service public
et les fonctionnaires ont besoin de
cette stabilité donc moi je vous le dit
l'organisation qui a été annoncé cet été
le fait que le siège de la préfecture de
région sera à dijon mais qu'il y aura
toujours une préfecture du doubs à
besançon et que les directions
régionales on voit leurs sièges répartis
de la manière que vous avez rappelé tout
à l'heure tout ça est pérenne et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut se projeter
non plus dans cette question de savoir
quoi et où
mais comment ça va fonctionner et
comment encore une fois ça va permettre
d'avoir un état moderne plus efficient
plus efficace plus économe de son
fonctionnement et avec un meilleur
service public rendu c'est ça le sujet
saissac attendent aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des citoyens finalement ça va évoquer
quand même tout à l'heure que la
prochaine piste de réflexion ça pouvait
être les sous préfectures mais parce
qu'on peut pas rester immobile
oui le territoire change et que
forcément à terme la carte des sous
préfectures qui pour l'essentiel je le
rappelle date quand même de 1926
on ne peut pas rester définitivement la
même il trop tôt pour dire qu est-ce qui
va bouger
mais bien sûr qu'on réfléchisse à ça de
la même manière qu'eux on a revu il ya
quelques temps l'organisation des
services départementaux
parce qu' on s'était bien aperçu qu'il
fallait bouger alors je rebondis sur ce
que vous avez dit vous avez dit la
question sait plus quoi et où c'est
comment et est ce que finalement ce
comment n'est pas le même depuis à peu
de choses près la révolution française
et la tradition jacobine on sait qu'en
france tout fonctionne autour d'un
centre est là le modèle qui est proposée
finalement c'est un modèle un petit peu
différent de ce qu'on faisait jusque là
alors bon on peut parler de moyens
modernes mais est-ce qu'au delà il n'y a
pas dans les mentalités à la fois dans
le fonctionnement de l'état mais
peut-être chez les élus aussi des
changements extrêmement important à
mettre en place qui seront peut-être
beaucoup plus long qu'un simple
déplacement
vous savez il ya j'ai toujours pensé que
le contrepoint de la décentralisation
c'était la déconcentration
c'est à dire se fait que on donne aux
autorités locales plus de au sein de
l'état plus de possibilités d'agir plus
d'autonomie avec une logique de moyens
et de résultats
et ce phénomène de la déconcentration il
est essentiel il ya la charte de la
déconcentration qui a été adopté par le
gouvernement avant l'été
elle donne plus de pouvoirs aux préfets
elle donne plus de pouvoir aux chefs de
service
elle va permettre vraiment de rapprocher
l'administration territoriale des
besoins des habitants et elle va donner
aux agents et je crois qu'il faut pas
que les fonctionnaires et peur de cette
déconcentration
parce qu'au contraire elle permettra
finalement une gestion beaucoup plus
intelligente à la fois des ressources à
la fois d'avoir des objectifs plus
clairs et des réalisations plus visibles
avec des spécialisations pour chaque
capitale où ex-capitale besançon
revendique maintenant une spécialisation
en économie et environnement avec la
dréal et la direccte par exemple oui
mais cette idée de la spécialisation
elle me semble aller dans le bon sens
j'ai proposé effectivement que puisque
le siège de la direction régionale qu'on
appelle la dréal qui s'occupe plus
particulièrement des questions
environnementales
sa compagne du siège d'un symptôme
d'opérateurs de l'état
a comme l'ademe peut-être qu'on n'avait
pas mentionné au début la validation la
future implantation régionale de
l'agencé française de la biodiversité
puissent être également à besançon on va
créer des pôles un peu des pôles
spécialisés
je crois que là aussi ça correspond à
une vraie nécessité parce qu'on créera
également un mode de travail en ce1 au
sein de l'ensemble de ses services
dynamiques
ludovic rochette vous lirez agir parce
que vous êtes l'élu l'on parlait de
décentralisation et moi je me ferais
l'avocat du diable pour vous titiller un
petit peu vous parliez tout à l'heure
des habitudes des dotations de l'état
donc vous voulez de la décentralisation
mais vous attendez quand même que l'état
vous donne de l'argent donc la
décentralisation n'est pas vraiment dans
toutes les têtes
six fois plus sérieusement si mauvais
que si on veut que l'état développe par
exemple le travail à domicile il faut du
haut débit
il faut des moyens technologiques pour
pouvoir le permettre partout c'est là où
les collectivités locales interviennent
et donc focalisé le moyen d'intervenir
et d'investir les collectivités locales
serait fort aujourd'hui
alors sous parfois l'impulsion le
contrôle
on pourrait utiliser d'autres termes
parfois de l'état mais par exemple
l'intercommunalité
la tonalité l'intercommunalité se
réforme
actuellement on a des cartes qui vont
bientôt apparaître sur les nouveaux
périmètres
c'est bien la preuve que les élus ne
sont pas du tout dans une situation
sclérosé par rapport à toute évolution
vous parliez de la fin de la clause de
compétence générale est ce que c'est pas
retour en arrière sur la
décentralisation parce que c'était une
façon pour les collectivités
d'intervenir sur ce qui leur semblait
bon eh oui mais on n'est peut-être pas
dans la même situation économique
aujourd'hui comme 1981 1982 aujourd'hui
on doit avoir des compétences qui sont
fixés on n'a plus les moyens d'assumer
d'autres d'autres compétences que les
compétences légales
on en est là aujourd'hui oui si vous
permettez j'aimerais effectivement
réagir parce qu'elles ont une petite
inquiétude qui équipe qui peut faire
jour dans les milieux économiques
c'est le fait de savoir si cette charge
supplémentaire
qui va peser sur les collectivités
territoriales dont d'ailleurs les
effectifs sont en augmentation
importante au niveau national et donc ça
s'est également dit confiant que la
fonction publique d'état diminue en
termes de nombre d'agents et que dans le
même temps les collectivités locales en
recrute des agents alors qu'on sait que
les dotations de l'état vont diminuer
donc le budget de fonctionnement va être
un peu squeezé et il faudrait pas que ça
se traduise par une augmentation de la
fiscalité notamment aussi bien vers les
particuliers que vers les entreprises se
seraient tout à fait contraire à
l'intérêt collectif
oui juste un petit remarque quand même
sur le sur les chiffres comparés des
l'évolution comparée des administrations
d'état et territoriale
il faut quand même rappeler qu'il ya eu
l'énorme paquet des agents des lycées et
des collèges en partie cela aux
transferts de compétences effectivement
ne serait-ce que ça a plus
l'inventaire du patrimoine mais non mais
c'est ce qu'on entend quand même
beaucoup c'est que les collectivités
territoriales ont largement créer de
l'emploi alors que l'état fermé le
robinet oui enfin ça se calme eu
beaucoup quand même
faudra gérer un peu quand même prendre
des exemples tout à fait récent la
gestion des fonds européens par les
régions puisque c'était transfert aux
régions se traduit par des créations
nettes d'emplois dans les conseils je me
sens en paya france à cette excuse moi
mais dans un pays où toute action
politique le but de toute action
politique l'alpha et l'oméga c'est la
lutte contre le chômage est ce que c'est
bien finalement que y ait moins de
fonctionnaires juste pour préciser
peut-être que en grande partie les
emplois qui ont été créés pour ces fonds
européens
ce ne sont pris en charge par des fonds
européens n'ont alors là je comptais ce
que vous venez dire je suis désolé il
semblerait que ce soit le cas qu'en
partie c'est à dire qu'il ya vraiment
des créations de je suis obligé de ma
fille je obligé de vous couper sur ce
débat certes passionnant qui nous un
petit peu éloigné du thème de la de la
matinée c'est la fin de cette première
partie on se retrouvera juste après pour
les questions qui nous ont été posées
sur le site internet de bourgogne et
franche comté et pour l'instant c'est
l'heure des informations aujourd'hui